das urteil ist gefallen eine lebenslange
haft im prozess um den tankstellen mord
in idar oberstein ja dort hatte dieser
mann den jungen tankstellen watt in die
stirn geschossen weil er aufgefordert
wurde eine maske zu tragen
alle hintergründe hat jetzt unsere bild
reporterin elisabeth cd die den prozess
für uns verfolgt hat lisa was hat sich
da sechs monate ging der prozess heute
als das urteil fiel vor gericht
abgespielt
ja also die richterin die kam rein und
hat auch ohne vorworte direkt das urteil
verkündet die mutter des getöteten
jungen die war die ganze zeit mit im
prozess mit drin als nebenklägerin und
als das urteil verkündet wurde die
lebenslange haft da fasste sie sich an
den nun dann ans herz und fing an zu
weinen also sie schien gerührt und
erleichtert zugleich weil die
verteidigung von mario andy hatte ja auf
totschlag plädiert was eine bedeutend
geringere strafe ergeben hätte die
verteidiger meinten es könnte eine
spontane tat gewesen seien deshalb nur
totschlag als urteil gefordert hatten
das konnte natürlich aber so nicht
beibehalten werden weil das dass eine
spontane tat gewesen sei kann in dem
sinne so wie es abgelaufen ist überhaupt
nicht nachvollzogen werden ich mein
mario ndr ist extra noch mal nach hause
gefahren nach dem ersten streik hat die
pistole geholt ist zurückgekommen hat
sich sogar angestellt die maske extra
unter die nase gezogen um alex w zu
provozieren und hat ihn dann in die
stirn geschossen als alex wie ihn
nochmal auf die masken pflicht
hingewiesen hat also demnach mord und
kein totschlag keine spontane tat das
heißt wir können heute nach diesem sehr
schnell urteilsspruch heute sagen der
mann kommt nie wieder raus
ja nie wieder ist relativ in der
deutschen rechtsprechung also wegen
mordes lebenslang verurteilt zu werden
das sind auf jeden fall mal mindestens
25 jahre was wie es danach weitergeht
das steht auch immer im ermessen der
gutachter
dieser gilt vielen herzlichen dank mit
seinen informationen zum tankstellen
mord von idar oberstein das urteil ist
gesprochen es war mord und der killer
muss lebenslang ins gefängnis
[Musik]